[Música]
y
el micro está
puedes ver al señor que está tendido
habla de nosotros mismos y del interior
pero yo soy geógrafo y entonces voy a
hablar del territorio y voy a hablar del
territorio próximo entonces
carlos cuando comentamos el tema que
íbamos a tratar de distintas propuestas
eligió este porque de alguna manera nos
hace ver en nuestro doctor jekyll y
mister hyde y es que somos capaces de
grandes horrores pero también somos
capaces a la hora de relacionarnos con
la naturaleza de hacer las cosas bien
por eso
funciones
se llama romper y tejer ecosistemas es
verdad que nuestra relación con la
naturaleza a veces es difícil o nosotros
la hacemos difícil probablemente porque
muchas me centro nos sentimos que somos
parte de ella y aunque existan
recomendaciones si no hay una cultura
territorial y una cultura ambiental pues
pasa lo que pueden ver en la imagen en
la que en la imagen de la izquierda a
pesar de que se recomienda que no sea
cercana y porque esa planta como luego
veremos es muy importante para este
ecosistema pues la gente le da igual y
ponen la toalla y en la imagen de la
derecha pues cuando hay gestión y cuando
y vigilancia realmente pues esa planta
que es tan importante se llama ballan
kong les adelantó el nombre pues
puede ser que se regenere y con ella se
puede regenerar la playa y quizás el
ecosistema
he elegido las áreas costeras porque son
para empezar somos islas y para seguir
pues son unas áreas que ahora mismo
cada vez nos gusta ocupar más unas veces
es un oscuro objeto de deseo porque
construimos incluso cuando contranatura
y otras veces pues somos más amables con
el territorio en el que nos incorporamos
en el caso de ocupar las costas pues no
somos nada originales porque en los
últimos en las últimas décadas pues el
proceso lleva a que prácticamente el 40
por ciento de la población mundial de
una manera o de otra ocupa franjas
costeras en españa es todavía más
singular porque es el 50% en sólo el 9
por ciento del territorio eso implica
una presión sobre los ecosistemas
costeros muy altas y en canarias pues no
nos hemos librado de tal forma que
aproximadamente el 12 por ciento de
nuestra costa es tan tan artificial
izadas que ya no ofrecen ni bienes ni
servicios ecosistémicos
estamos en una media con respecto al
resto del estado pero no es una alegría
estar en ese promedio
sin embargo al mismo tiempo que las
costas sufren esta presión son medios
fascinantes porque los litorales las
nuestras costas son unos medios de
transición entre la tierra y el mar
entre el agua dulce y el agua salada
entre los sedimentos que aporta un
terreno y el arena que nos viene del mar
y a partir de ahí se crean formas de
vida vio estás muy singulares que son
precisamente de medios intermedios pero
al mismo tiempo con tantas interacciones
pues las hacen frágiles de tal manera
porque como luego vamos a hablar
de un sistema dunar pues tenemos que
entender que los litorales como ocurre
con otros ecosistemas no son unas fotos
son una película son dinámicas de tal
manera que se intervenimos en una parte
de ese ecosistema pues a lo mejor
podemos tener problemas en algún otro de
tal manera que el cual que existe el
ciclo del agua del que antes nos
hablaron pues está el ciclo de la arena
la arena se produce en la zona submareal
a partir de los restos de los organismos
vivos y del material lítico que se
genera cuando se mete oriz a una roca y
a partir del movimiento de la deriva
litoral pues emerge y en esa forma de
emerger otro agente distinto el viento
pone a esa arena circular unas veces se
sedimenta y se estabiliza y otras veces
vuelve al mar y se genera un ciclo de
alimentación con todas esas
interacciones imagínense si en el
circuito de repente fallar y guantes
hablábamos del circuito del agua pues el
circuito de la tiene su interés y nos
podríamos preguntar qué ocurre si en un
punto de ese circuito nosotros
intervenimos e intervenimos sin conocer
cómo funciona que es a veces lo grave
pues para responder y ya que estamos en
maspalomas pues vamos a ver si alguna
respuesta quizás yo ahí lo puse maldigo
maspalomas tiene la respuesta y digo más
palomas tiene una respuesta es un
sistema playa duna que se localiza en el
sur de la isla como ustedes saben y que
tiene pues dos playas la playa en inglés
y en la playa de maspalomas y aparte
distintos ambientes un ambiente de dunas
móviles un ambiente de dunas
estabilizadas por la vegetación luego
veremos por qué una laguna costera a la
que nosotros llamamos oasis cuando nos
ponemos finos y charca de maspalomas
cuando estamos más normales y luego pues
tenemos como ustedes conocen toda una
secuencia de edificaciones que ya se van
imaginando que algún problema han
generado
uy
lo que les voy a contar porque antes
hemos ido hablando de equipos son
investigaciones que desde hace 10 15
años distintos grupos de la universidad
de las palmas de gran canaria con
colaborando con otras universidades
tanto estatales como internacionales
hemos ido desarrollando y me parece
importante una primera clave para
analizar el presente y proyectar el
futuro puede entender como ya han dicho
quienes me han precedido que estas cosas
nunca se hacen solos y como no voy a
citar los nombres prefiero que le vean
las caritas primera como era maspalomas
bueno pues maspalomas como antes dijimos
con respecto al ciclo de la arena tenía
un sector que es esto que ustedes ven
aquí aunque no lo parezca en la playa
inglesa que está ahí
[Música]
a ver si consigo no cambiar
aquí estaría hoy el anexo y esta es la
terraza del inglés que está entre 20 y
30 metros en otras partes en torno a 60
metros la arena entraba por la playa del
inglés fíjense el volumen de arena que
había que era capaz de traspasar la
terraza y aquí verán el faro pues salía
por la playa de maspalomas y luego la
deriva marina y según las variaciones
estacionales entre el invierno y el
verano devolvía la arena y volvíamos a
tener este circuito en funcionamiento
que le ha pasado a este sector pues bien
que es un sistema que al final las
edificaciones lo han ido acorralando y
en concreto en la terraza del inglés
pues lo que hemos generado en una
pantalla eólica de tal forma que el
sedimento que tendría que entrar desde
en inglés encuentra una barrera de
edificaciones eso hace que en unas
partes se acelere el flujo de olic o y
que en otras se ralentice o quede
completamente anulado y a partir de ahí
que es lo que nos vamos a encontrar pues
que el grano de arena que tenía que
entrar por la playa del inglés ya no
puede atravesar la terraza y ya no llega
más palomas como consecuencia de ello
cuando hemos estudiado cómo evoluciona
el perfil costero pues hemos visto que
la playa inglés más o menos está estable
en ese balance de la arena que entre la
que sale pero la de maspalomas erosiona
entonces al erosionarse pues
periódicamente las personas que son de
aquí lo habrán vivido aparecen problemas
muy significativos en uno de los
sectores que son de alguna manera la
playa es
el elemento emblemático de todo el
desarrollo turístico que hay alrededor
qué es lo que de alguna manera nos ha
ocurrido bueno pues que hemos ido
dialogando mal con el ecosistema en el
que queríamos desarrollarnos y qué pasó
con la laguna que es un personaje
importante en lo que yo les quiero
contar bueno pues que entre 1959 que el
entorno estaba bastante natural y
aproximadamente finales de los años 80
pues fue sufriendo
un proceso progresivo de deterioro de un
espacio en el que tendríamos una laguna
costera periódicamente conectada con el
mar cuando corría el barranco se
conectaba cuando no el sedimento cerraba
y formaba más un sistema lacustre con
una colonización vegetal importante con
una dinámica eólica perdón significativa
a partir del desarrollo turístico del
finales de los años 60 pues lo que vamos
a ir es ocupando no solo el entorno sino
también la propia charca al punto que se
convierte en un lugar muy deteriorado
con aguas residuales con un escaso
desarrollo de la vida y con una serie de
artefactos como el antiguo tel duna que
realmente pues no es lo más apropiado
para un ecosistema que tiene tanto valor
natural
a finales de los años 80 pues realmente
el escenario era doloroso una carretera
que casi llegaba hasta aquí aquí
aparcaban los coches una serie de
edificios agua contaminada y a partir de
ahí y yo creo que es la parte del futuro
que un poco que se quiera reflexionar
con estas jornadas pues empiezan a
aparecer voces desde distintos entornos
que quieren recuperar ese espacio que
consideran que ese espacio tiene tanto
valor porque fíjense en una laguna
costera en canarias donde no hay agua es
un punto clave para que las aves
migratorias puedan descansar pueden
edificar entonces de los pocos puntos de
agua permanentes que tenemos y nos lo
vamos a cargar y hay que agradecerle a
un montón de instituciones y a un montón
de personas el que desde finales de los
70 empezarán a dar voces diciendo que
eso no podía continuar así y de ahí que
bueno pues en una fase pre
constitucional pues ya empiezan algunas
iniciativas de
protección
luego ya aparece una figura de
protección como similar a la que se
tiene ahora pero sobre todo aparece un
proyecto centrado en la laguna costera y
luego en la actualidad pues una tercera
fase en la que se quiere intervenir en
el conjunto del espacio y ahí pues
realmente lo que vamos a encontrar
es que ya que estamos volcánicos estos
días pues hay un enjambre de voluntades
en las que algunos elementos actúan como
calidad catalizadores un biólogo un
alcalde un periodista y que
permiten que vayan progresivamente en
torno a un proyecto colectivo que era
recuperar la charca vayan consiguiendo
engarzar distintas voluntades y en ese
sentido
también la difusión tuvo una importancia
muy grande en la fase previa denunciando
y en la fase posterior poniendo en valor
lo que se estaba haciendo se estaba
quitando aparcamiento se estaban
levantando carreteras y eso la población
lo tenía que entender y lo tenía que
asumir pues bien pocos ecosistemas
costeros protegidos cuando serán ustedes
en los que se hayan eliminado el cadáver
de un hotel que nunca se llegó a
terminar y eso pues realmente es indica
el interés que en un momento dado la
sociedad tiene sobre un espacio pero
claro no es la sociedad son las son
todos los colectivos que van animando a
que eso se haga o por ejemplo un poco
más tarde el que se llamó el proyecto
oasis 2000 en el que lo que se quería
era recuperar la charca y todo su
entorno y a partir de ahí pues lo que se
van a hacer es una serie de actuaciones
tan básicas como quitar una fosa séptica
quitar una carretera e impedir que los
coches lleguen hasta el agua eliminar
eso ya no es tan sencillo pero se hizo
eliminar un hotel o un centro de litera
pico que tampoco estaba facilitando la
cuestión
bueno pues cuál es la
evolución que tiene este espacio pues en
prácticamente 10 años pasamos de la
imagen de la izquierda que era un poco
pues territorio comanche a la imagen de
la derecha en la que empieza a
reconstruirse un ecosistema que
indudablemente no es el que había es
otro nuevo pero que ha conseguido
renaturalizar un espacio artificializado
por la actividad humana
el otro ejemplo bueno antes de seguir
esto no es gratis entonces aunque esto
es el dinero presupuestado y no es el
que realmente se gastó
estamos hablando de un presupuesto de
casi un millón y medio de euros en dos
años en 2000 o sea es decir que meter la
pata luego cuesta caro es sacarla el
otro proyecto que es el que está ahora
lleva unos años se está iniciando es el
proyecto más dunas que lo lidera el
cabildo en el que también está en la
universidad en el que también está el
plan y están otros organismos pues lo
que intentan es plantearse el futuro de
este espacio ya no una actuación
concreta en la laguna sino una actuación
global hay acciones
localizadas como eliminar las especies
exóticas o las especies invasoras
eliminar una serie de estructuras que
con la vegetación han hecho a las
personas y que deteriora un entorno es
todo menos una reserva natural especial
y la actuación más significativa
consiste en ustedes volvemos ahora a la
terraza del inglés consiste como ya la
arena no puede hacer el circuito que
hacía antes porque ahora se acumula en
este punto y de este punto pasa a la
zona submareal y ahí hay una baja de 1
es considerable en la que la arena no
puede volver otra vez a superficie pues
lo que se hace es de manera artificial
se coge arena aquí y se deposita aquí
donde era su entrada natural a partir de
ahí que es lo que se quiere conseguir
bueno pues ese flujo que nosotros
rompimos volverlo a re tejer que de ahí
un poco el título y que al mismo tiempo
esta zona que es la duna costera se
pueda regenerar porque es necesario que
se regenere esa de una costera y porque
esa imagen del principio en el que
criticaba que la gente no respetará los
barrancones y se metiera y bueno pues
porque esta línea que ustedes ven
esa duna en montículos que hay una
planta que favorece porque al final las
dunas es una relación entre la vida la
planta y la dinámica de la arena pues
gracias a ella esto nos erosiona si esta
duna costera desaparece el mar entra
hasta el interior y nos quedaríamos sin
playa no sólo esto sino todo el sistema
como hemos visto antes por lo tanto pues
lo que se pretende de alguna manera es
poder a partir de captadores de arena e
implantar todas las especies que han ido
de zapatos ejemplares de balancán que
han ido desapareciendo y conseguir el
que se vuelva a tener estado una costera
que es la mejor protección contra el
posible la posible subida del nivel del
mar ante un escenario de cambio
climático determinado y que cualquier
otra solución pasaría por
soluciones muy duras de alta ingeniería
así que me perdone el ingeniero
sin embargo la naturaleza te da las
claves que a veces la forma más
importante de intervenir es imitarlo o
recomponer un poco lo que has roto
también esto tiene unos costes altos
estamos ahora en un presupuesto en torno
a un millón doscientos mil euros que no
son bromas pues bien ya para concluir
que es lo que cuál es nuestro desafío
pues ser conscientes que restaurar ya no
podemos un ecosistema alterado será otra
cosa cuando intervengamos en él lo que a
lo que podemos aspirar es a rehabilitar
pero rehabilitar como hemos visto es
costoso y la manera más barata de
rehabilitar un ecosistema es a la hora
de intervenir en el primero usar la
ciencia conocer cómo funciona luego
apoyarse en los técnicos que son también
muchas veces los que a pie de obra saben
lo que hay que hacer y lo que no hay que
hacer y como alguien decía hace un rato
no tomar nunca decisiones selecciona la
playa vos cogemos un tractor y venimos
para acá y para allá no no las cositas
tienen que ser pensadas pero la manera
más barata más barata para rehabilitar
pues es precisamente no alterar ese
ecosistema porque lo que sí es cierto y
con esto ya terminó
es que como parafraseando esa canción de
una murga plátano maduro no vuelve a
verde es decir que el ecosistema que
nosotros tenemos
difícilmente va luego a volver a lo que
era podremos aspirar a que sea algo más
natural en consecuencia bueno pues
nuestra manera de tratar a la naturaleza
tiene que cambiar necesariamente
buenas tardes y gracias
[Aplausos]